[Music]
in Landlord impostor news while you
pretending submitted by Mateo from
Woodland Hills
hello Mateo a man has been accused of
breaking into a home and renting it out
that's pretty smart that's pretty smart
right that's amazing yeah so the
original tenants just are never there
that's why I see that like maybe the
original tenants just have that home or
something yeah he chose well doc that
place for a while he that you know I
know realtors are coming in here yep but
if you came home and there were
strangers in your house are you allowed
to kill them I would first try to figure
out what they're doing and I would play
the game so if they're like trying to
sell me the house I pretend like I don't
own it and then give them a really
vulnerable yeah yeah and then I would do
some fun stuff like what paper trail he
actually came up with all of the actual
paper like all the documents and they
look legit but he fabricated every she
was depositing their money like checks
wiser so he actually made about five
thousand eight hundred and twenty five
dollars off of rent from these victims
and apparently it was multiple victims
they don't mention how long he was
renting this place for but obviously it
was quite some time because he even
remodeled parts of the home and this
whole hugh put he hung up
but like picture frames of himself to
like sell it like that was his home did
you do I think you lost money you only
made five thousand eight hundred dollars
he remodeled the homes he [ __ ] put
Victor's and furnished it well it was it
was someone's home but they were in
vacation in Mexico for like an extended
amount of time and so that's the time
when he went in and he started renting
out the property like if it was his and
apparently for one of the renters he was
trying to cash a check in exchange for
drugs to I bet you it was a family
friend that knew they would be in Mexico
for that yeah they do mention that he
did know that they were gonna be gone
for that long and that he found the
spare key
I think there are people who are
inherently sociopathic like that like we
listen to a podcast called dirty Jon
have you guys heard of that no are you
gonna listen to her yeah it's amazing
but basically this guy cause the woman
into making her believe that he's this
anesthesiologist so he he lives with her
for months and he just wears scrubs
everything comes home like leeches
offered completely but like you know
comes in the hole like doctor garb and
she freakin buys his old story well he
doesn't pay rent or anything like that
mm-hmm and because she doesn't confront
them and yeah yeah I'll get it to you
I'm just a doctor you know some people
are just very gullible and compliant
have you guys ever been conned I don't
think so I think I've been conned really
feel like I should have I know because
I'm pretty gullible too
you are well you got that timeshare
that's kind of oh yeah I did yeah I did
good I was living in that house I'll
just tell you the story real quick
that's okay I'm interested yeah you cuz
you don't seem like it I want to know
tell me more and I get a knock on the
door and this is white guy there with
long hair it was a deal what's up I was
living in San Diego I'm friends with Jay
Jay Schweikart and a new JJ was my boss
at the coffee shop yeah oh yeah Jay and
he got a dude I just came back from
Mexico last night you're next no door
neighbor John let me park in the back in
the alleyway my car got towed and it had
$5,000 in it and a grand worth of
marijuana by that towed I don't have the
money because the money is in the car
can you go to your bank account give me
the money for the tow and then I'll give
you like $600 ho ho so I go oh yeah
because I only had 150 bucks in my bank
account so this fool gets in my car I go
to the bank I take my last 150 out for
160 we go drive downtown and then he
goes wait pull over here my sister lives
here I want to go say hi he runs it as
an apartment complex and I'm just like
an idiot sitting there right and as time
goes on I realize he ain't come back
and it walked into this apartment
complex and the back gate was open so he
had ran through so I went to my friend
Jess Walker could this girl just call me
he did this and that anything what Jay
said so this guy always does that oh how
did he know your friend he just he's so
he just took his name and then how did
he know he also apparently goes too
because we a lot of he's scammed a lot
of people he goes to people's mailboxes
he memorizes neighbors so he can have
his cuz he mentioned magnetic next-door
neighbor he meant CA he had all these
things you know that I wouldn't convince
me that he knew all these people and
some people just live and there and
they're the con artists and they don't
have any remorse you could confront them
till there and tell them what they're
doing is immoral and they it does not
sway them at all
so only beating bare ass probably helps
not even that oh they were just your
violin and mean right mmm we have to
live in this world with all kinds of
people mm-hmm and that's just it's a
pity and a shame you know you have you
know you have Mexicans I love them I
love living with Mexicans but you know
you have life you know we're in the room
I don't know no no what I'm saying is is
that we have to live with like KKK KKK
people that want us dead but we to live
in the same country as them I don't
think they care about Asians they don't
know that we exist
where we are ninth on the list yeah yeah
we're the last it's like it's like
blacks no Jews first Jews and and and
Middle Eastern and then like Tuesday I
think oh yeah I think Jews Middle
Eastern second and in and then black
blacks yeah
then Mexicans yeah cuz they're taking
our jobs yeah Mexicans and then were
next I think we're like non-existent but
you know you know if they ran things we
would pretty much be safe I think to get
all the Jews Mexicans are crafty Yeah
right you're not gonna be able to catch
them easy yeah well you can't catch them
cuz you can't tell who's a Mexican and
who's not
that's all done they are you guys also
know the topography of the land I mean
you guys are good with that yeah yeah
good climbers you know yeah yeah yeah
our vertical is insane it's insane right
so it would if they went in order the
KKK we gotta get the Jews does that be
easy that would be pretty easy
that's pretty [ __ ] hard using what I
can't tell what right that's gonna be
hard right oh my god look really here
but the last we could change the last
name in high yeah some of them some of
them have the nose a lot of babies that
racist a lot of white people that's
right sister well but there's a certain
curvature there's a certain curvature to
the nose you don't have a regular Asian
no but there's a certain curvature to it
you know Zoe Natalie Portman's Jewish
five hundred percent yeah Chen cheese oh
yeah she's a hundred percent so you
could tell to the dark hair no you can't
that's her point
look that's yeah they're all she looks
Mexican I do look Mexican side and I
look Jewish well technically no you
don't bite per your Jews would take a
while could get the differentiate
between the whites and the because
there's like European East West European
Jew Mr P and you it's all like what's
the east easiest one go to identify
african-americans black yeah cuz they're
black yeah they can't hide they can't
hide you get hot yeah yeah yeah you can
tell there's a black guy there's no you
know even if they're mix right he's you
know although we know one guy that's
half black but he looks a hundred
percent white yep he looks kind of
ginger oh I see yeah he's one of those
yeah so he probably will get behind but
then when they go down the list and they
did it in order it would it would never
come to us I don't think it's gonna take
too long well they're not gonna go past
the Jews it's too much work already
right
yeah that's already too much work well
and then I think the Jewish people are
way more rich than the KKK so cuz they
own all the media and pinks that's
another thing they have the money yeah
they have all the power you have the
power of the money you can't do it
you're the best defense yeah that's good
that's why I came as long as we don't go
near the trailer park we're fine yeah
the forest with the cabin yeah we're
safe yeah so this dude obviously got
arrested the guy that rented out the
place and he also stole thousands of
dollars of electronics and he even
damaged a property even though he like
repaired some of it this guy was clearly
on drugs it would have made fifty eight
hundred which is not much
yeah there's easier ways to make money
than to do all that that's why I'm
saying he probably lost money yeah you
did a lot of it even to fixing the house
and [ __ ] and buying [ __ ] he seems really
motivated I don't know huh just get your
real estate license really flipping
homes you're obviously very good at it
right I'd make way more money flipping
homes would you be okay with it though
if you told your friend like you're
gonna be out of town for a week you come
back and a house is better and it's more
it's it has better furniture a money for
you yeah and then it's like you bet yeah
man I've been meaning to fix this wall
there you go there's like family living
there
oh yeah it's give and take right yeah
what about you what if you went home and
all of a sudden there's people living
there
well I think that gives me the legal
right to to do some damage to the
victims you know because they're also
victims
it doesn't matter but we're in
California I don't view you as a very
violent person you ride huh I don't
think I would I talk all this trash but
when it comes down to it I don't
probably let it slide in fact if I came
over to my house and people living there
I'd be like I'm gonna leave I'll get a
hotel it's sure you are very tender I'm
very tender you guys have you ever in
your relationship like had a physical
altercation mm-hmm is it cool yeah not
like punching each other we've thrown
[ __ ] at each other yeah I feel like
Bobby it that's it that's not in his
wheelhouse he's so tender yeah I'm a
tender person like he might like do that
like you didn't yeah I'll slam things
yeah yeah and slam that way yeah but
I've never really been you know when I
got beat up by Ari Shaffir as a stand-up
and he punched me and I didn't even
fight back he just kicked me in the face
like 50 times why it's over a lie that I
didn't do anything wrong and you know
fight back no I was just in that I was
in the corner looking at my face like
this it was at a comedy call that sucks
dude right
I was believing from every orifice Wow
and I stood up and I was believing and
then I heard my name being called to
perform and I walked up on stage and I
didn't stand up with my face all
bleeding
yeah it's Asian work ethic
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]